Today's Designed by Drew viewer thinks he's here
for some design advice and has no idea that we actually
have a brand new room waiting for him.
So let's meet Chris who went from being homeless
four years ago to now, being the proud homeowner
of a four bedroom house.
Oh!
I know!
(applause)
Check out this.
(gentle urban music)
Hi, Drew, my name is Chris.
I'm 24 years old, and I live in Williamstown, New Jersey.
I fell on hard times in 2016.
I was a freshman in college
and I was working full-time and going to school full time.
And I had to pay for school out of pocket.
Unfortunately, when I was 18, I became homeless
and I was living out of my car for,
it was like six to eight months.
And it got to a point where I had literally pennies
in my account.
I just decided to turn my life around.
I didn't like where I was
and I wanted to be in a different place.
The next day, I must've applied for over 2000 jobs.
Eventually I got my first real job selling mattresses.
I was still homeless.
I actually was able to go back
to school and I went to an online coding academy
and I got my first engineering job
and then a second one.
But I decided that I wanted to buy a house
because I wanted to have a place
for my children to grow up and have a stable place
and a yard that's big enough for them to play
and somewhere where they can actually call home.
So I bought my house.
I was able to save up enough for it.
My next goal is just making my house a home
for me and my kids.
I truly believe in taking life
by the horns and manifesting your own happiness.
I believe that no obstacle is too great.
(applause)
Chris is here now.
Hi, Chris, how are you?
I'm okay, thank you for having me.
May I ask, how is everything
for you now in your new home?
It's great.
I'm used to living in apartments where it's kind of cramped
and you know, maybe one bedroom, maybe a few
hundred square feet or something.
And now I have this pretty decent
sized house that I'm really proud of.
And I love just being able to wake up
seeing all the things that I've built, put together,
and that I am still building for.
So it's great.
This was the first time in my life
where I was actually happy about something that I did.
And I think I needed that to help me be proud
of myself and see that what I did do was something great.
What was it about this house, may I ask,
that spoke to you and said, this is the dream.
It was the perfect foundation.
I was thinking of it, of what I can turn this into.
And it had everything laid out.
I loved how big the yard was
because I want my kids to be able to run around
and have a place to play and, you know, hurt themselves
and come to me.
(laughter)
You know, and have friends come over and have barbecues,
have birthday parties in a place
where they can always call home.
I saw the big backyard and I was like,
that's definitely something that I want.
I saw the rooms that it had.
I saw the basement that I was turning
into a theater, because I went to the attic,
which I was turning into a library slash art room.
It's the foundation that I wanted that said,
this is exactly what I need to get started
to make it the dream house that I want it to be.
Well, that is so well put.
And you have two beautiful children,
your three-year-old son Carter, and Xavier is on the way.
Well, then I think there is something important
that we're gonna need to do.
And I was wondering if I could involve myself
in your new son's room, Xavier?
Absolutely, absolutely.
Please do.
(applause)
Okay, good.
So you haven't started on your son's nursery, right?
Right, it's a blank slate.
Thank you for letting me be a part of this.
This was your son's room as it is now.
And here is what I would like to do with it, ta-da!
(applause)
Oh wow!
Which, basically Chris, I kind of already went and did.
I hope that's okay.
That's completely fine with me.
Okay, this is Xavier's new nursery and you are
gonna get every single thing that you see in here.
And we were lucky enough to work with Pottery Barn Kids,
one of my favorite stores
and we just had your baby boy in mind.
And here is three design tips that we really got into.
All right.
We thought about using bins for shelving
because you can kind of quickly take stuff in there,
throw it in there, put it back.
And it'll just look really neat and tidy.
Also, we have a toy chest here
and those really, really help and this is a really
great one that doesn't allow any finger accidents to happen.
Also, I did wanna bring a little color into it.
This is actually a Flower Home piece of artwork
and we kind of went with like an animal jungle theme.
And the reason I chose this crib
is because, I'll show you.
When you bend over it,
there's actually a dip for your waist.
And I can't tell you how many times I have jabbed my ribs
my xiphoid process, my solar plexus
trying to get that baby in and out.
Whoever figured this moment out,
on behalf of every parent and their chests, thank you.
I so appreciate that.
All right, now I like this chair
because I specifically placed it in this area
of your room because this chair is the power position.
It can see the door that you enter
because I wanted who's ever sitting in this chair
with little Xavier to feel like whoever is coming in
and out, you can be seen directly.
And we did these decals on the walls so
that you could feel that fun jungle animal motif
and keep it going with the rug and the walls.
But we tried to keep it delicate
and not sort of overdo every space on the wall.
So this is it.
I can not say thank you enough.
You just blew my mind and this is probably
the nicest thing somebody ever done for me.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Words can't express my gratitude.
Thank you, Chris.
And thank you to Carter and almost welcome
to Xavier and we'll check back in
and see how everything is going with you.
(upbeat music)